well today we're having the opportunity
to be guided through the world of
chemistry and our guide is professor and
Valentine and she's going to talk to us
a little bit about medical metals and
we'll find out shortly what that all
means now some interesting things about
professor Valentine is that she grew up
in Pittsburgh and she went to school at
the University of Virginia and then MIT
and when she was in college she was a
competitive swimmer anybody out there a
competitive swimmer I like to swim all
right well you've got some good company
and another interesting tidbit is that
she actually was a floor or dorm a dorm
resident for professor Erin lavik so you
can see we're all kind of connected all
right so well anyway without further ado
let's welcome professor Valentine to the
podium Thank You editha good morning
everyone well welcome to my talk this
morning which is as advertised about
medical medals this is me anum valentine
here's my email if you find after today
that you have questions and you want to
ask questions I encourage you though to
interrupt me with questions if while I'm
talking something occurs to you or you
want more explanation please by all
means speak up it's fortuitous that I'm
speaking this morning because it turns
out this week in case you didn't know is
national chemistry week you have to
search the hallmark section pretty hard
to find the cards but in fact it is
national chemistry week october
twenty-second of the 28 so maybe some of
you guys in your schools will have some
special programming i celebrated
national chemistry week by by getting
the official national chemistry week
tattoo they go mucci so that all of you
can similarly celebrate we have lots of
national chemistry week tattoos and and
you leave some students will be giving
you some lovely door prizes which
include proper tattoos so you can
celebrate in grand style this week so
how this is our American Chemical
Society mascot the mole on the tattoos
it explains why but you see we get we
have little mole as our inspiration for
the day so he can just sit right there
so I want to start I want to get
something
the way at the very very beginning by
talking about what a chemist is and what
they do and so I want to see what you
all think about this definition of the
chemist so what do you think about that
one here's the Kear's the sort of
stereotype of a chemist he's that he's
an old guy and he's got white hair and
he's looking googly eyed and crazy you
know so so what do you think is this a
good definition no not a good definition
I mean sometimes it's true some of my
best friends fit under this description
but it's not always true and so I'd like
to start again about about what a
chemist is and what a chemist does
chemists study the molecular nature of
matter and and how it interacts with
other matter and how it changes so we're
really deeply obsessed with atoms and
molecules that make up stuff and how the
stuff changes and and what it can make
so for example it could be that your dad
as a chemist when he makes you a grilled
cheese sandwich if you are really hungry
and the sandwich isn't cooking fast
enough what do you do you turn it up
right turn up the heat and it makes a
cook faster well you know why does that
work maybe you don't think about it
every time but in fact you're doing
chemistry on the grilled cheese sandwich
maybe your sister's a chemist when she
puts these crazy teeth whitening strips
on right what are those things anyway
how do those things work not talking
about white strips today maybe maybe
you're a chemist when you get one of
those glow sticks at a fair or a concert
right and you all know if you go home
and you want it to glow again the next
day you stick it in your freezer right
and that makes it last more well we know
why does that happen that's that's sort
of strange so even though you may not
think about it every time you're in fact
surrounded by chemistry and chemical
principles impact you all the time we
also have some glow sticks for you at
the end so you can practice this part
yourself they're blue and white yell
colors yeah so so the particular kind of
chemistry that that I work on with my
students is bioinorganic chemistry it's
about metals in biology and at the
beginning that might sound a little bit
weird
and I want to spend a minute talking
about bioinorganic chemistry so it turns
out that by about 1,800 there was a
division in chemistry between the
chemistry of the molecules of life which
was called organic chemistry now organic
means you pay more for it in the grocery
store but originally it meant it was
carbon-based and a molecule that made up
a biological organism and at the very
beginning that was thought to be
different in some profound way by some
mystical you know process that was
thought to be different from the
molecules of same minerals or stones or
ores and that was in organic chemistry
and the funny thing is we've known for
almost 200 years that this is a false
division so this gentleman volar is
credited with sort of completely putting
to rest the idea that inorganic
chemistry and organic chemistry are
separate things so the experiment that
he did was he converted ammonium cyanate
which is was known to be inorganic and
he converted it to urea so i want to
show you those molecules i have them in
a couple different forms because i just
want to remind you the way that chemists
represent molecules okay so here's
ammonium right its NH 4 and there it is
up don't have enough hands there it is
up there so this is nh4+ here's cyanate
now some sicko stole all the nitrogen's
from our chemistry molecular model kit
this week can't find him anywhere so I
had to sort of make homemade one so all
through my today's lecture the blue tape
tomalak or atoms are nitrogen that's
right there was only one left they
teased me right they left just one
that's almost worse than none now they
don't match okay so here's ammonium here
cyanate right this is ocn and what volar
did was he heated that and he converted
it to urea which is this molecule which
has the same atoms make a urea bracelet
right okay and so it has all the same
atoms as the other molecule but in a
different
binding orientation and urea was a
product that was known to be organic
volar knew this because it was isolated
from urine so it was organic it was a
biological process and this in 1828
really showed that there's no difference
between the molecules the atoms of
organic and inorganic chemistry but we
still maintain this division and we sort
of joke about it so there's sort of a
healthy rivalry really between the
organic chemists and the inorganic
chemists now I just get another reason I
showed this slide is to remind you of
another sorry for my area down to remind
you of another way that we represent
molecules which is like this so this
representation is equivalent to this one
to save space sometimes we just write
the atoms and h4 and chemists also right
arrows like this to show that some
reaction happens so voters reaction was
ammonium and cyanate reacted to make
urea over there okay so that will see a
couple times again this sort of way of
representing another way of representing
molecules okay so with that out of the
way that now I've assured you that
there's nothing weird about inorganic
elements being in biology because
they're all just elements the particular
thing that people like me study is the
involvement of elements other than
carbon in biological processes and here
are three examples that might come under
this heading so first of all some
biological molecules naturally contain
metals my example here is emma globin
right now in each of your blood
hemoglobin contains iron and it's
transporting oxygen to your tissues and
so we need this for life a second
example to to admit the downside is that
some metals are poisonous and so for
example lead is poisonous to humans and
lastly some metals are used in medicines
to combat illness and disease if you
take pink pepto bismal the active
compound in that is a bismuth compound
and so that is one example of a medical
metal we'll get to another one later
today I'd like to talk about the first
and third of these things one reason is
because I'm generally optimistic I don't
want to talk about metal poisoning
another reason is because I
to do demos doing demos of metal
poisoning might be not such a good idea
to convince you guys to go into hmmm
into science okay now it turns out that
lots of medals are important in biology
and this is a periodic table now as a
chemist I'm contractually obligated to
show a periodic table within the first
six slides it's necessary I really like
this one because it only shows part of
the periodic table and it cuts off the
part with carbon so that makes the
organic chemist mad it's up here
someplace I don't know so anyway this
shows the the metals that are important
in biology and particularly it shows the
ones that are naturally involved in
biological processes in red and shows
ones that are involved in some kind of
drug or probe molecule in gray okay so
so we have a lot to choose from for our
talk today lots of metals are important
in biology but before I talk about
specific cases I want to get one last
thing out of the way which is to be very
clear about what it is that I'm talking
about so if you guys imagine a metal you
probably imagined something like my car
keys right so they're hard they're you
know they conduct electricity sometimes
this this kind of metal is not what I'm
talking about today if we imagined let's
start with iron if we imagined solid
iron you know a hunk of iron metal
that's not the kind of metal that's
usually involved in biological processes
instead what I want you to imagine is
imagine just taking one atom out of that
hunk of iron metal okay so here it is
this iron atom has got 26 protons that's
what makes it iron it's got maybe 30
neutrons and the atom if it's neutral
has 26 electrons and you guys know the
atomic structure says the protons and
neutrons are the nucleus the electrons
are around the outside right okay so
everybody's color-coded here
mmm now if I could ask you now to
further imagine taking three of those
electrons away so here we have what we
call an iron ion so the iron still has
the 26 protons it's still iron it still
got the same number of neutrons but now
it's lost three electrons and so it's
got an overall plus three charge okay so
now we're closer to what biology uses
last thing I want you to imagine is I
want you to imagine finding stuff to
that iron and we call that stuff ligands
so often metals bind six things ligands
like this and when they do that they
make an iron three-plus complex so my
point is that generally in biology we're
not talking about hunks of metal being
involved in some process we're talking
about metal complexes so maybe just one
or just a few metal ions bound to other
stuff okay so that's a little bit
different than what you might imagine
about metals okay now with that
introduction then I would like to tell
you two stories today one of them is
about the first of the the first of
those three involvements of metals I
showed you before about how a metals
involved in a natural biological process
that protects you and the second one is
going to be a story about a medical
metal as promised the story of the most
successful metal-based anti-cancer
medicine so my first one is about a
metal in an enzyme so few definitions
first of all an enzyme is a catalyst
made by biology a catalyst is something
that makes a reaction that's already
favorable that's key a catalyst can't
make something happen that's not going
to happen that doesn't have a favorable
reaction on its own but if something's
favorable a catalyst can make it faster
and the second part of the key is that
the catalyst can't be changed by the
event the catalyst remains unchanged and
can go on and catalyze the reaction over
again so my analogy here is that if you
introduce
two people to each other and then they
become friends they clearly had
something in common right you didn't you
didn't make them be friends they they
both like soccer whatever they had
something in common they were going to
be friends but they might never have met
each other and so if you introduce them
then you are a catalyst for their
relationship and doesn't have changed
you any you can go out then and
introduce other people and have them be
friends also so in biology we have
molecules that do that same function
which as we'll see is a darn good thing
for us and I i also want to admit
somewhat grudgingly that i don't want
you to go home thinking that every
enzyme has a metal in it because they
don't all my favorite ones do but they
don't all so the one we'll see today
does have a metal in it so the
particular enzyme we're going to talk
about today is one called catalase it's
got an easy name to remember right it
catalyzes stuff its name is catalase
that's good and it it really addresses
the fact that as all of you breathe
oxygen now remember we said your oxygens
carried to your cells by the hemoglobin
so there's one iron involved there
inside your cells you respire that
oxygen and the intended product of
respiration is water so you're inhaling
oxygen you're making water and that
happens most of the time but not all of
the time and so the bad thing that
happens about twenty percent of the time
is that the oxygen doesn't get all the
way converted to water it stops part way
and so inside your cells you make a
little bit of hydrogen peroxide now many
of you may have seen hydrogen peroxide
in the grocery store it's in the first a
dial-in little brown bottles and the
reason that you buy in the grocery store
is because you use a disinfecting so if
you get a cut maybe you guys have done
this right you put a little hydrogen
peroxide on the cut and what happens it
burns it does burn it kind of fizzes
right your little fizz eNOS and your cut
okay what you're watching there is the
hydrogen peroxide damaging any bacteria
that might have gotten in your cut
you're probably damaging your skin a
little bit
too but but you have a nice protection
you know your skin this gives you good
protection from everything below so the
reason that we that we buy this in the
grocery store is to kill cells and you
could imagine it's really bad for it to
get made inside your cells right it can
go and damage the molecules in your
cells and so the good thing is that we
have an enzyme catalase enzyme that
speeds up the destruction of hydrogen
peroxide okay so here's what happens
here we have two molecules of hydrogen
peroxide I again have some here just to
show you right so here we have the two
molecules of hydrogen peroxide right and
these convert to sorry these convert to
oxygen and water so one molecule of
oxygen here it is I had lots of oxygens
just the nitrogens were stolen and two
molecules of water and those are shown
up there okay now remember i told you
that one of the important things to
remember about a catalyst is it can't
make something happen that's not going
to happen anyway and the conversion of
hydrogen peroxide to oxygen and water is
really a favorable and it'll happen by
itself so you might wonder why bother
with a catalyst then but the reason why
is because without catalase it takes a
really long time for it all to go away
and so if you made some hydrogen
peroxide inside your cell it would take
about a year for half of it to go away
and that's a pretty long time because
you're making it all the time you don't
want those those hydrogen peroxide
molecules staying around but if you have
catalase then it goes away half of it
goes away in about a minute okay so
we're going to watch this guy in action
today so first of all I would like to
make sure you notice how safe I'm being
right we're going to be very got gloves
on see what they didn't make cool purple
ones now so you don't have to look quite
as dorky as your parents might remember
looking in lab got some I cool safety
glasses right okay so here
here I have some hydrogen peroxide now
this is more concentrated about 10 times
more concentrated than what's sold in
the grocery store because I'm a
professional so we're let this is a
better demo with with more hydrogen
peroxide and so far this demo is really
really boring because it kind of looks
like water right so that's pretty boring
but in fact what you've seen poured out
here is thirty percent hydrogen peroxide
I'll move to the middle sort of so this
is a this is thirty percent hydrogen
peroxide it pretty much looks like water
and if we had a year to wait we could
wait for half of it to go away but I
figure probably some of you have other
stuff to do you know and they need this
classroom for Monday so so we need to
make it go away faster okay now what
we're going to use is this enzyme
catalase and I wanted to show you the
molecule the core of the molecule that
catalase uses to do this reaction now
look sorry didn't think about the lab
coat lab coat microphone issue okay so
so catalase uses a core of its molecule
looks a lot like hemoglobin so on the
Left I'm showing you the hemoglobin
molecule that brought the oxygen to the
cell at least the core part of it the
part that binds oxygen Oh surprise sorry
I over here on the right I'm showing the
part of catalase that does the chemistry
so they look a lot like each other don't
they and part of what fascinates a
chemist is you know how come this
molecule binds oxygen but this one
doesn't think different if they look so
similar this is the kind of thing that
that keeps us off the streets okay so so
we're going to see catalase at work I'm
going to put some catalase in that
graduated cylinder and we're going to
convert the hydrogen peroxide in just a
second now turns out that a lot of the
catalase in your body is in is in the
liver believe it or not and so what
we're going to do today is use the
catalase in liver a specifically chicken
liver to convert that hydrogen peroxide
so
I went to the grocery store this morning
actually three grocery stores and and
got some chicken liver you would not
believe the looks you get when you go
into the grocery store to buy coffee a
muffin and chicken liver at eight
o'clock in the morning um so uh hang on
a second so um all right should have
opened this before I it's a difference
not my usual brand no it's true I do go
to a different store any liver would
work that's a good question so what the
heck um I thought it opened this well
enough any liver would work because any
organism that breathes oxygen I'm
actually I'm okay oh sorry any organism
that breathes oxygen has this problem
with not completely converting its
oxygen to hydrogen peroxide so so beef
liver would work all that stuff okay so
I'm going to put the chicken liver in
here and and the question is what are we
going to see okay so here's what we're
going to see so the hydrogen peroxide
looks pretty much like water right so
seeing that convert to water there's
nothing to see but the oxygen that gets
made is going to make bubbles and so the
main thing that you're going to see is
the oxygen making bubbles and it kind of
is going to foam up much like the
hydrogen peroxide that you put on your
skin when you're cut okay if you were up
here you might feel the hydrogen
peroxide getting a little bit warm
because heat is another product of the
reaction ok so now so here we have the
chicken livers right yeah yeah okay so
here we go hydrogen peroxide chicken
liver ready and there it goes see ya
pretty cool right okay so hang on okay
so let's talk about what's what's going
to happen them so yeah sometimes like a
little little crazy and it foams over
the top so we'll see how how crazy I got
so what's happening is right these
bubbles are coming from the oxygen
that's getting made from the catalase
and the catalase itself is just turning
over and it's able to turn over multiple
times and so by the time what it'll do
is it'll consume all the hydrogen
peroxide that's in here and then it'll
be ready for more so I could at the end
of this poor more peroxide in and the
reaction should start up again okay so
you're what you're seeing that is the
action of this iron catalyst yeah it's
pretty gross okay yeah yeah you could so
this is mainly pure oxygen coming out
the top although it's not on such a big
scale that's right the catalase is a
real catalyst and so it can just keep
turning over and over if you if it if
you cooked it it wouldn't work as well
because the protein that's around it
would all unfold and it wouldn't really
work so well but as long as you don't
cook it you can you can do that so we'll
let that just bubble can be a semi
disgusting distraction for you guys
while I'm talking you have different
ways of making it so when when not a
very good biologist but when a white
blood cell engulfs something I think it
can produce some hydrogen peroxide like
on the spot but it's not the same
hydrogen peroxide that gets made this
way yes
it's not going to be a big difference
because the even even this hydrogen
peroxide is still only thirty percent so
it's still seventy percent water and
it's true some of the hydrogen peroxide
would convert to water but I've never
seen a noticeable volume change that you
can't buy more concentrated hydrogen
peroxide in this it's little dangerous
little explosive okay so and actually I
wanted to say before I before i go into
something else that hydrogen peroxide is
the thing in those white strips right so
remember earlier in my intro of
chemistry in your everyday life we
talked about i mentioned the the white
strips you put in your teeth to whiten
them and it is peroxide that's on those
strips so that's why they have a show
this is why they have a shelf life so
when you go and you if you find some
expired you know expired white strips
and your cabinet you wonder is it safe
to use them it's safe but they're not
going to do anything because the
hydrogen peroxide is decomposing because
it has the tendency to do that all by
itself and even more so if you put it on
your chicken liver can't imagine why
that would ever come up okay so anyone
else have questions about about catalase
before we do something a little
different yes in the back yeah catalase
is iron so here's here's the iron right
in the middle that's the yellow yep
anybody else yes question in the back
yes but not as well so there's less
there's a little bit of catalase and
lots of kinds of tissue but there's the
most in liver and so yeah you can use
hamburger other stuff but this is that
the the most the highest concentration
so it gives you the best foaming yes the
well there are some small differences in
the heem but mainly it's the protein
around it is different I know yeah so so
there are some small differences so like
you know just to pick one out right this
is different from that for the protein
around them is all different but but
you're right they look a lot the same
and and you know how such similar
molecules could do different chemistry
is a totally profound question that that
we all think about okay anybody else on
catalase okay so then in that case my
summary of part one the enzyme catalase
in liver which has an iron atom at its
core protects you from the leaked
hydrogen peroxide that you make during
respiration by making it convert faster
to oxygen and water right in the cells
right right the molecular respiration
yes yes the hydrogen peroxide is dead
attacks other kinds of molecules so it
attacks DNA for example it makes breaks
in DNA that would be one bad thing that
would happen so it's reactive I mean you
see the fizzing and then so that it
might make a mutation in DNA yeah yeah
just nonspecific bad stuff yes
it makes free radicals yeah hydrogen
peroxide itself is not a free radical a
free radical has an unpaired electrons
but it makes 0 it dot which has unpaired
electrons and is a free radical so it's
kind of on the way there although it
isn't itself one okay part two part two
is the story about the medical metal so
for those of you who are here two weeks
ago you've actually seen a little bit of
intro to this but I wanted to start
today's talk with another demonstration
so so here we have in the front you may
have noticed my green beakers and those
beakers contain nickel sulfate so fresh
gloves so nickel sulfate is a metal salt
and I brought some that's a that's solid
just you can see so just right ok so
there's solid nickel sulfate it's
beautiful green crystals this is why
it's good to be an inorganic chemist
organic chemistry they don't have pretty
colors usually so can you tell i'm a
little bit you know get a little biased
yeah that's okay though okay so here's
nickel sulfate crystals here's a nickel
sulfate solution that i made right it's
the same pretty green color and then
over there are six nickel sulfate
solutions that are a little more dilute
right so we can see the color changes
okay so what's already happened then in
mind my dilution is that I took nickel
sulfate solid the solid green and I
dissolved in water and it made this
beaker here which is those beakers there
which is the pretty nice green color
right so the molecule that's made inside
that beaker is the one that I'm showing
you here so here is a nickel 2 plus ion
so remember Nichols a single atom of
nickel has lost two of its electrons to
make an eye on and it's got waters
attached to it so there it is it looks
kind of like this and that's what's
floating around in those
in beakers hmm another way to draw the
thing is like this sorry get rid of
disgusting stuff so you can see some
other way to draw this is is this way so
this these are equivalent ways that a
chemist might represent the molecule and
this is another one so nickel with six
waters overall to plus charge and it's
bonded kind of like this okay that's
what's in that's what's in the beaker
now you might wonder why that thing has
color right so the reason that it has
color is because I'm reminding you so in
nickel 2 plus there are 28 protons a
little different than iron 30 neutrons
and 26 electrons it's two plus and these
electrons are the important part these
electrons are why transition metal
complexes have color and most organic
molecules don't because what happens is
those outer electrons absorb light
energy and they get excited to a higher
energy level and when they absorb light
you see a different color than white
light so in this case the nickel is
absorbing the red from the room light
and it's making it look green to you so
you're seeing what's left over right and
so every time you know the lights
hitting that thing the court electrons
in the nickel get excited to a higher
energy level and they take the red right
out of the light and so you see the
other stuff okay so that's that's why
you're seeing you're seeing green
because the outer electrons these
outside electrons out of this group are
getting absorbed are absorbing light and
getting excited to a higher energy level
right okay so now let's do some
chemistry with it so what happens if we
take this complex this nickel with six
waters and we add some ammonia to it
okay so this is just household ammonia
like you might use to clean the floor so
let's start with this
ok now I'm going to leave this beaker
the same right this one's always going
to be the same hexa a quo here on the
end so you can see that one and we'll
add stuff to the others ok so often
people like the stir plate better than
anything else I do we use these things
in lab so the students don't have to
stir all the time right it's got a
little magnet at the bottom and it's
stirring around to mix the solution ok
so so first I'm going to add to the
first one some some ammonia ok assuming
I can get the thing open ok ok so here
we go ready
this is also good this is a pipetter so
automated so you don't have to use a
bulb or anything like that okay ready
here we go actually there's a little
more
it sure it's all the way blue okay so
that wasn't eat right that one turned
blue okay so what you just saw what you
just saw then oops sorry was was that
right ish I mean it's not quite the same
color but close and what you're making
there is this molecule this one has all
of those waters that used to be bound to
the nickel exchange for ammonia nh3
molecules right so this is the thing
that's in that beaker now and again we
could write it some other different ways
to save some space right that would that
would work too so this thing with
different ligands bound to it has a
different color than the one with the
water bound to it so that's weird how
does that work well here are your two
the two things I've made so far and the
reason that they're different is because
they have different ligands bound to
them so you could imagine right if if
I'm the nickel hexa a coil complex right
and I need to get up an energy level
right okay here i am i'm at an excited
energy level now jumping on furniture
was bad for tom cruise's career well
we'll see what it does for mine okay so
so here I am right I'm the nickel X
equal I've even got a shirt that matches
today how could I mean you know right so
I'm I'm the green one right it took a
certain amount of energy for me to do
that right to get up here to this higher
energy level if I were a different
complex if I were one of you smaller
type people you could imagine it might
take you a different amount of energy to
get up here on the table with me so it's
not it's not wait exactly the weight is
an analogy that i'm using but a
different complex with different ligands
bound to it takes a different amount of
energy to get excited to a higher level
right and that means the light gets
absorbed a different color so
so the energy of the light that's
absorbed by those outer electrons is
really sensitive to what's bound to the
metal and that's why these nickel
complexes have different color so the
one is absorbing to make it green with
different ligands the absorption makes
it blue but it's all the same metal and
that's another thing that inorganic
chemist think is really cool okay so
enough jumping on furniture so here so
here again are your two things that
we've made so far okay let's let's find
something else we'll find something else
to the metal okay so the next thing I
want to bind to the metal is something
called ethylene diamine sorry about my
cooler so ethylene diamine is down here
this is the next ligand that I want to
use so one reason a darme it like this
is to again show you the tyranny the
horrible horrible tyranny of the organic
chemists when we don't show an atom it's
assumed to be carbon how rude is that
they just assume its carbon so so here
this this molecule has nitrogen carbon
at this corner carbon assumed nitrogen
and this particular molecule is called
ethylene diamine so the next thing we're
going to do is add some ethylene diamine
okay so what I'm going to do here is add
just a little bit of ethylene diamine to
the first beaker okay so here we go
okay ready
okay blue again but kind of a different
blue when you say looks a little bit
different than the first one yeah that
one made us all I don't know if you guys
can see what that one kind of made a
solid on the left hand side this one is
still pretty clear so it's a little bit
different ok so the complex that we made
the color looks something like that the
the complex that we made is this one so
now we took what used to be six waters
and we replaced two of them with those
two nitrogens ok and so writing the
atoms on it looks kind of like that and
we might make the cartoon like this so
here's the nickel with this molecule
bound to it and the other four waters ok
so now there's the three that we've made
so now let's make something different ok
next I'm going to add more of the same
thing ok so so here we go
it turns sort of a darker purple right
so that complex with the darker color is
this one so now we put enough of the
ethylene diamine inch replace four of
the of the waters and we make this
complex here so this has to earthly and
I means and still chew waters on it
again this is another way that we'd
write it and maybe like this so here are
the four things that I've made so far ok
and now now we can stop and make a
prediction if I added a little bit of
ethylene diamine I got one on there if I
add a little more I get to on there so
what do you hypothesize would happen if
i added a lot of ethylene diamine one
two three thank you yes three okay so
we'll see we'll see if that happens okay
so with this beaker then I'm going to
add a bunch of it make sure do this from
the back is better
ok so now that's a little more just for
good measure ok so now it made yet a
different color this one's purple right
so this one so here we add even more
ethylene diamine we get this thing thats
dark purple and now it's got three so
every every water is replaced by an
ethylene diamine and we might draw it
like this and abbreviated like that so
now here are all five of the things I've
made so far but I have one more beaker
and so with this one last speaker I want
to add get a different yet a different
molecule which is in here ok with my
last speaker I'm going to add this
compound which is called dimethyl gly
oxime it's a little bit bigger than the
other ones we've seen but again these
this is a carbon here at a carbon and
it's got these two nitrogens which looks
kind of similar to the ethylene diamine
and when we add this one to the mixture
oh god extra store bar in there it it
turned red right it turned red and it
made a solid so i'll leave the after
you're done you can come up and check
this out sorry i'll stop the ringing
noise so uh so what you've just seen
there is the following reaction this so
there's the dark red and the molecule
that we've made is this one so it's got
just two of these dimethyl I oximes
around the nickel and it looks a little
bit different it's only got four things
bound to it and it makes this red solid
so here's a cartoon of what happens and
then here's the full range of every
compound that we've made ok so in every
case there nickel to all the same
except they've got different stuff found
them and that makes them all different
colors yes question the overall complex
doesn't because each of the ligands has
a minus one charge that's advanced yes
you
that's right that's right so this this
oxygen that this is sort of advanced to
the hydrogen's kind of shared between
these two oxygens in this complex but it
makes this solid red okay so so what the
heck right I why are we looking at all
these nickel complexes other than the
fact that I think it's really cool it
makes nice colors okay here's the
periodic table i showed you before and
here it shows you which metals are
important in biology and i promised you
a story about a medicine and I'm talking
about nickel which is not gray so the
ones that are used in medicines are
supposed to be gray and this one's not
so so what's the deal well the reason
I'm talking about nickel is that Nichols
in the same family with platinum and I
do want to talk about platinum that's
the the story of the day and the reason
that the periodic table exists the way
it does is because of these
relationships among elements in a family
so one column we sometimes call a family
on the periodic table and it's a time
it's really hard to the lab coat okay
the reason that we call these these
vertical relationships families is
because they have properties in common
it's a lot like your family may be so
you know you could sort of imagine that
Platinum's like the big brother of
nickel right and if you imagine that
this row is like your class at school
with all kids about the same size ish
and then this would be some higher grade
and that would be some higher grade if
you had some big brother in another
grade you might have a lot of stuff in
common right you might look like you
might like the same movies you might
both play soccer but also there's some
chemistry that's that's there's some
differences in people that's different
so I have a little sister she always
hated the fact that all the science
teachers thought that she would like
science because she didn't very much
like science so just as with elements
you you have to be a little bit cautious
you can't assume that the little brother
is going to be just like the big brother
or sister but but often there are a lot
of properties they have in common right
and frankly I couldn't afford to do this
demonstration with platinum platinum is
really expensive and also
and I wanted to have you know tattoo of
money left over so um and also and also
frankly nickel makes better colors so
that's why we're doing with nickel but
we're the comics want to talk about is
the big brother of nickel which is
platinum and as you'll see the platinum
complex is going to look a lot like this
nickel complex here so just hold that
thought you know for a minute okay so
that's why so so again this um some of
the chemistry of this work was covered
by dr. Iona black who gave a talk two
weeks ago I had already promised to talk
about medical metals and frankly this is
the best story in bioinorganic chemistry
and I could not let go of it I had to
tell it anyway so you saw some of the
chemistry from her but I'm going to tell
you some other parts of the story just
because frankly I can't resist doing it
so this gentleman here Barnett Rosenberg
had a really good idea in 1965 which
starts the story he thought about
magnetic field lines that were around a
magnet so this this is an experiment in
physics right if you take a bar magnet
like one of my sister bars and you shake
iron filings around it you it they
orient themselves to define field lines
right maybe you've seen that in physics
and that those field lines kind of
reminded him in some way of the spindles
that form during cell division so we
have a an insight from physics and an
insight from biology that came together
in his head and he thought you know
these but these field lines look kind of
like these spindles and so he wondered
if maybe cell division might be some
kind of electromagnetic phenomenon now I
need to tell you that he was wrong about
that right but it doesn't matter the
story has a happy ending as you'll see
but my point is that great ideas don't
always have to start out on the right
track so so Barnett Rosenberg had this
good but wrong idea the experiment that
he did was he grew e.coli bacteria
recently in the news for invading
spinach and making people sick but we
use them in the lab a lot they're not
always dangerous he grew them in a petri
dish in the presence of platinum
electrodes and he put like a field
across the electrodes and what he saw
was this really weird behavior in the
cell so here he coli cells that look
normal and when he grew them in this day
with his electrodes and hooked up to a
power supply the cells did really weird
stuff they got bigger and bigger and
bigger but they never divided so that
was weird right but luckily Rosenberg
was a really careful scientist and so he
did the control experiment and he turned
the power off and the same thing
happened so imagine you know if your
television at work you know if your
television at home worked without the
plug-in you might think something
strange was happening and so clearly
this effect he was seeing was not
anything to do with what the power
probably made the electrodes react
faster but but he could he could plug it
in for a while take it off and the
effect persisted so clearly there was
something interesting difference going
on and luckily he had the persistence to
not just throw the thing in the trash
and go home he diligently figured out
what was happening and it turned out the
punch line of the very long story is
that this molecule cisplatin was the
chemical agent causing the change and so
I made this sort of homemade cisplatin
for you there also aren't metals and the
molecular model kits more tyranny but I
made some and I also have you know make
my usual homemade nitrogen's so here's
here's cisplatin own it's actually the
other orientation isn't it on this and
the inch it's very reactive molecule um
so so so this thing had actually been
made more than a hundred years before so
when I was showing all that nickel stuff
you know those are all complexes that
are just just for fun just for show at
least today right and 100 years ago
people had made complexes just like this
just to make them you know not with any
medicinal application mind just for the
basic research these had already been
made in 1845 in 1893 Alfred Verner
figured out what the structure was and
turned out this thing was medicinally
active against these cells so that's
that's all very cute you know making
really big e coli is like a good party
trick right but but ultimately that's
not so applicable right and so the thing
that made this really exciting is that
cisplatin cured tumors in mammals and so
i'm going to show you one disgusting
mouse picture
but it has a happy ending for the mouse
okay so this is a picture from
Rosenbergs original 1969 paper and you
can see this poor mouse has got a tumor
here under his armpit see it's a big
lump and when this mouse was injected
with this compound cisplatin the tumor
over many days got smaller and smaller
and smaller and mouse also that fatter
and fatter and fatter you can see um but
by day 36 the mouse was was cured and so
this and lots of other experiments like
it really showed that this funny thing
that happened in bacteria had profound
and really useful effects in humans and
so what happened after that happened
pretty fast that was a 1969 picture that
I showed you in 1971 cisplatin the
compound entered clinical trials in
humans and it was approved in 1978 any
of you who know about drug discovery
know that's blindingly fast it was
really very successful and this compound
is licensed by bristol-myers squibb just
up the road in wallingford and more
recently they launched a
second-generation medicine which is this
molecule carboplatin which is one that's
used today now this isn't a perfect drug
it's it's not active against all kinds
of tumors that's one big problem it's
causes bad side effects like a lot of
kinds of chemotherapy people lose their
hair they get very sick and it some
tumors tend to come back resistant to
the drug so sometimes you can beat the
cancer one time but then you know if you
don't get it all when it comes back
somehow the cells can resist the
medicine and so there's there's a lot of
work still to do about this drug but
it's really been incredibly successful
for many many people and I want to show
you one person you may know who was
cured by this drug so does anybody know
who yeah yeah Lance Armstrong so I
realize you guys are way cooler than I
am this is probably totally passé right
this is like so last year with the
rubber bracelets right but but at least
you know a year ago these rubber
bracelets were meant to support to
support Lance Armstrong who's this
gentleman and he's a spokesperson for
bristol-myers squibb and was cured
partly by these platen drugs as have
been many people and so this is now I
think about the third best-selling
anti-cancer medicine the most you know
best mostly used and again while not
perfect it's really cured a large number
of people and so it was an accident it
was an accident but it's been really
really a successful medicine yes well
there's a joke that he call it that the
cancer has been cured in e.coli many
times so you know you can do things
happen to any coli but of course you
always wonder about the human
applications and something that is that
that is so that affects cell division so
much you'd think about what it might do
to a cell that's dividing all the time
which is what a cancer cell does it
would more specifically damage those
than one that wasn't dividing all the
time nobody else okay so the way that
just real quickly because I'm going a
little over the way we think cisplatin
works is that it goes in and binds to
DNA and it kinks the DNA the way I've
shown so what actually happens is is
that the chlorides these two chlorides
come off all right chlorides come on and
it binds to a piece of DNA so if I'm DNA
the cisplatin binds to me and when it
does that it makes it sort of kink and
twist and that causes a lot of problems
with the copying of DNA and with the
reading of DNA and with the repair and
again as the question addressed because
tumor cells are dividing more often than
normal cells it's relatively more
damaging to a cancer cell than to a
healthy cell so that's the way it works
but that's there's an awful lot of other
biology and chemistry behind that rather
glib description so the summary none of
my second part is that platinum
compounds like cisplatin were
accidentally discovered to be very
effective medicines against cancer but
again they're not perfect and there's
still a lot of work that needs to be
done about them so if you'll just give
me like a minute at the end I just want
to say a few things about about
chemistry
because you've seen a couple different
kinds of science today and I think while
I admire all fields of science I think
there's you know amazing biology and as
as Rosenberg show there's really great
stuff that happens when you're aware of
both you know biology and physics right
at the end of the day I'm a chemist and
so so I think it's a fair question what
I think is the good thing about
chemistry so the thing there are two
things the first thing that I think is
really cool about chemistry is that we
get to make stuff and and so in a lot of
kinds of science including some kinds of
chemistry we try to figure out what's
true about nature what's true about the
world but chemistry more than some other
kinds of science gets to invent our own
new stuff you know make new materials
and make new molecules that have never
been made before and that is abuzz for a
lot of us you know that's that's pretty
cool and so when I say creative I don't
mean like creativity and experiment
design I mean actually making stuff and
that that's what attracts a lot of
chemists to chemistry and finally for me
quite frankly other there's this thing
that I like to call the Goldilocks
effect which is that I really liked
science a lot but for me biology is too
big biology is very complicated you know
there are lots of big molecules are
doing a lot of stuff and for me that was
that was big physics is either too small
or too big depending on you know if like
atomic physics is really tiny and then
astrophysics is really big so you like
Goldilocks right too hot too cold just
right for me science was too big too
small just right so i think there's
certainly a room for lots of kinds of
science I certainly would never say
anything bad about my colleagues in
science but for me for me these two
things that the ability to make new
stuff and the Goldilocks issue were the
two things that that made me a chemist
and so and so finally last I just want
to show in nature last month this
gentleman Philip ball went around and
surveyed a lot of really leading
chemists and asked them what the most
important questions in chemistry are
right now and so I offer these as sort
of a to-do list for for your generation
right here are the most important things
that really smart chemists they
are important things to know so first of
all how do we design molecules with
specific functions and dynamics how do
we make the next cisplatin be found on
purpose and not by accident right how do
we plan things secondly what's the
chemical basis of the cell what does
chemistry have to say about biology how
do we make materials that we need for
the future in energy aerospace and
medicine can we make a chemical that
gives us a better fuel cell can we solve
some energy problems can we store
hydrogen all of those things we don't
know how to do yet what is the chemical
basis of thought and memory so you know
that that is for the last I told you the
beginning there was nothing nothing
mystical about organic chemistry but
there's something a little mystical
about thought isn't there and so
understanding you know what chemistry
has to say about how memories are stored
is a pretty pretty profound question
speaking of profound questions how did
life on Earth begin you don't get much
more profound than that how could we
look forward if it happens on other
planets what should we look for what
conditions are necessary and finally how
can we explore all the possible
permutations of all the elements we make
stuff but we can't make everything
there's no way that we could make every
combination of molecules that are of
atoms in a molecule that you could
imagine and so you know how should we
address this problem how should we even
try or should we even try these
questions are are some of the most
profound and that are left to do for as
I said for your generation you know I'm
not so old I'll I'll have a crack at it
but um you guys have more time than I do
okay so so I just want to do two other
items of business one is a nice student
asked me to put up this slide
advertising SciQuest 2006 if you are
hooked on science and you want to see
some more the nice kids who do the Yale
demos group are having a thing on
Saturday November for that's whitehall
there's an email down here at SciQuest
2006 at yahoo and i believe they're
going to have handouts for you when you
go so you can get your I think I've
probably had more fun than anyone today
because I got to
Mick stuff right so you could do that
too and I also want to thank really
thank professor Aneesa Ramirez this is
the last science Saturday's talk for the
year and Aneesa does a wonderful job
organizing and promoting this so I'd
like to have everyone applaud thank you
yeah